in a rare interview the chairman of the
Federal Communications Commission tells
CBS this morning he will crack down on
robo calls more than twenty nine billion
robo calls bombarded Americans last year
and most of us don't like that that
amounts to roughly ninety robo calls for
every man woman and child with some
getting several calls every single day
Anna Warner shows us a new effort to
stop those calls to your home your cell
phone or your office - and a good
morning good morning well the Do Not
Call Registry debuted nearly 14 years
ago preventing many unwanted calls from
companies that follow the law but people
running scams don't necessarily care
about that law and they can now place
thousands of illegal calls for pennies
on the dollar the telecom industry
claims it's working to block them but
its efforts are complicated both by
legal hurdles and the difficulty of
tracing where those calls are coming
from it's not normal to listen to your
voicemails and immediately have people
yelling at you to stop calling them
Peter Clark hadn't called anyone yet
when he checked his phone he found more
than a dozen missed calls with messages
like this I think you have the wrong
number Peter hi you guys need a quick
call on my phone I don't have a credit
card this is ridiculous that's
unpleasant yeah it's called spoofing
when scammers make it appear as if robo
calls to others are coming from your
phone making the actual scammers nearly
impossible to track it's frustrating
there's literally nothing that you can
do to prevent yourself from being a
victim to this spoofing why is it taking
all these people the government and the
companies so long to fix this it's
exceptionally complicated new FCC
Chairman Ajit pie says tackling those
scams is a top priority I saw there was
our number-one area of consumer
complaints was robo calls was robo calls
there were 2.5 billion of those calls
last month up nine percent from the year
before this is Susan with credit card
relief you qualify for a seventy-five
percent savings and you are entitled to
receive a complimentary stay good
morning last year the FCC convened what
it called a robo call strike force made
up of 33 telecom and
at companies in a report last month the
group said it's working toward fixes
like developing a standard
authentication technology to verify
exactly where calls come from that's
currently not possible since any call
can go through multiple networks do you
have a deadline for companies to fix
this
we certainly want them to move as
quickly as possible and as aggressively
as possible some of it is difficult to
do because these are highly technical
areas do you think this problem will get
solved without significant pressure from
the government so far no Tim Marvin is
with consumers Union which two years ago
started a campaign to get the government
and phone companies to stop Robo callers
I think the companies could be doing
more they have made small technological
progress
it just isn't enough to actually solve
the problems in fact former FCC Chairman
Tom Wheeler said last year phone
companies should offer call blocking
services to their customers now at no
cost his replacement is a former Verizon
attorney will you insist that the
companies offer call blocking and other
technologies for free to consumers
that's one of the things I'm very open
to doing because I think that it's
important for consumers to have all the
tools at their disposal you say open to
doing though well there's some questions
about the legal authority that we're
working with the lawyers to figure out
in some cases we don't necessarily have
the authority to mandate something but
from a consumer perspective I think it's
a good idea
[Music]
whatever the hurdles Peter Clark says
companies should be doing more you know
you see all these line items for fees
fees fees so I would assume that I'm
paying the companies to implement fixes
the FCC is studying a proposal that
would allow companies to block numbers
they know are unassigned but of course
that might just encourage more spoofing
of numbers that people actually use
right now several call blocking apps are
available you might be able to use them
to reduce the number of robo calls to
your cell phone Nora all right Anna
thank you so much